[Music]
south korea has gone its own way in the
fight against the coronavirus
testing was core to its strategy at the
start of the pandemic
people used masks in private homes
an app closely monitored the population
enabling authorities to track infection
chains
the vaccination campaign also quickly
picked up speed
now over 40 million people in south
korea have received at least one jab
that means over 80 percent of the
population is fully or partially
immunized among the highest vaccination
rates in the world
but has south korea done everything
right
and what can other countries learn
welcome i'm ben fazoulen is it time to
learn to just live with covert that's
what south korean officials are saying
experts around the world view the nation
as a role model in its handling of the
crisis
let's take a closer look
it's a big moment for manager lim young
man
he's opening this daytime disco in seoul
for the first time in six months
it comes as the government loosens many
of the restrictions imposed because of
the pandemic
like the patrons the owner is happy but
also nervous
i couldn't sleep well last night i was
worried but also i was excited because i
can run the business again what i'm
worried about is what if i have to close
again with more confirmed cases
but the authorities are taking steps to
prevent their new plan to live with
covid from leading to a new spike in
infections
for high-risk venues like bars and clubs
visitors have to show proof of
vaccination or a negative test
and while curbs on opening times for
cafes and restaurants will be dropped
there will be limits on the number of
unvaccinated people allowed into such
places
the authorities hope this will mark a
new beginning for the country
we're taking the first step today to
return to the path of everyday life
and it's a path we've never been on
the moves to lift restrictions are
possible because more than three
quarters of the population in south
korea are fully vaccinated
but the government stresses that the
efforts to contain covert must continue
people are being asked to keep on
wearing masks
and to ventilate indoor spaces
in this way they hope all curbs can be
lifted by next february
illahagli lectures in medical law and
ethics at yonsei university in a report
you wrote the government strategy
k-quarantine flattened the epidemic
curve without a complete lockdown
gaining attention worldwide but you said
the country had to pay dearly can you
tell us more about that
yes the government did not complete
banned
the whole society but actually it equals
to the complete band because the shop
sets close at nine o'clock nine o'clock
and the schools are around
one-third or half
and the younger generation lost their
chance to get a job
so people
suffered for the
listening of the
chance to their free lives
so
that's what happened in korea
so practically practically it was a
complete lockdown um but a lot of people
were taking it upon themselves uh to
take on that responsibility what i'd
like to know from you is if the
government is in return supporting them
financially
but the compensation was
uh
distributed quite late at the year and
it was not
the full compensation compared to other
european countries like uk or germany
so
the self-employed people got agitated
by the
fact that they are not completely or the
fully compensated by the government even
though they cooperate very actively with
the government policy well what's going
to happen now because a lot of those
businesses are saying they can't afford
to close again is it too early to lift
restrictions or or is this the only way
to deal with pandemic fatigue because
health officials say more people are
ignoring social distancing rules as this
pandemic fatigue sets in
oh there was a survey that about 40
percent of the self-employed person
seriously considered close up their
shops
because due to the loss of incomes and
heparins they have to pay
so
their agitation and their
loss of trust for the government
makes forced the government to lift the
ban or because the government
cannot say that
saving lives are everything because we
have to restore the society and also we
have to deal with this
injustice
uh what is inherent in the society i so
understand where people are coming from
because i've just been taking a look at
some of the laws this this cap on on
on unvaccinated people in cafes of up to
four unvaccinated people in a group
doesn't seem to make sense to me the the
100 people who can attend concerts and
musicals regardless of vaccination
status and then jim's no longer limiting
treadmill speeds because of the worry of
all that sweat i mean are these the
sorts of very specific rules that
only cause people to shake their heads
or worse still not even follow the rules
yeah because the government uh tried to
very specific
for
uh not to fully restrict the society
but uh in their attempt to
uh
not to close the society in the whole
society down but
the only possible way is make more
complicating laws
uh to deal with it but the self-employed
person and social society in general
is complaining
about the law the policies because it is
it looks very unreasonable and also
the application is not
fairly applied to every uh
to each of the every people group
and on top of that we've got winter
coming we've got delta around and cases
remain high although
this 80 vaccination rate seems like such
a success
why
is that not mirrored in the in the case
numbers
uh from the other phases korea has taken
the aggressive testing and treatment
policy i think this is can be one reason
of high numbers of the infected person
so far
16 million have been tested kobe 19
compared to south korean population is
48 million so one third of the korean
population in math
have been tested so the number could be
very high
and when i checked national statistics
about two-thirds of the patient are from
metrosol area which is one of the most
densely populated in the world
and also we need to pay attention to the
20s and 30s who constitute
33 of the compound cases they are most
active in the social relationships and
the least vaccinated growth so this
could explain the legality below
the the younger generation is
can explain the relatively low mortality
rate but
high
the impacted impaction rate
ilhackly thank you very much for your
insights and interesting talk coming to
us
from south korea there the medical law
and ethics division of yonsai university
thank you
time for one of your questions now
here's our science correspondent derek
williams
when will the novovax vaccine be rolled
out
novavax is an american biotech firm that
has developed a vaccine candidate which
produced promising results in
large-scale trials
those results
are currently being evaluated by medical
authorities in a number of places
including the eu
last week
indonesia became the first country to
approve the vaccine for emergency use
the company says that it expects other
countries to follow suit by the end of
the year
approval in indonesia though alone won't
be enough to secure approval from the
who which is
necessary if the novavax vaccine is to
play a role
in the kovacs initiative there it could
have an especially big impact
on the vaccine drive in poorer countries
because of how it's made the platform is
different than that used in vaccines
approved
so far in western countries they are
based on
information bearing molecules like
messenger rna which causes the
recipient's body
to produce copies of the viral spike
protein which ultimately leads to an
immune response against the virus
the novavax vaccine however contains
copies of the spike protein itself which
are produced in insect cells in
bioreactors
they draw the attention of the
recipient's immune cells setting a
cascade of events in motion
that includes the production of
antibodies against sars kobe 2 spikes
and hopefully
long-term immune memory of them one big
upside of the platform is that
the spike proteins are quite robust so
they don't need to be kept at ultra low
temperatures to remain stable
that makes the vaccine a good potential
candidate
for distribution in places where cold
chain issues
are a challenging factor
[Music]
and before we go a quick look at some of
the other covert stories making news
a 20-month u.s travel ban is over fully
vaccinated travelers from over 30
countries can now enter the united
states the european union lifted its
restrictions on american travelers back
in june
russians have returned to work after a
lockdown to contain the virus ended the
country reported nearly 40 000 new cases
on monday that's despite the closure of
most offices and public places since
october 28th
stay safe and see you again soon
[Music]
you